Transcriptor: Ruby La Cruz
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
¿Te has puesto a pensar que
la astronomía es sexy?
Ser sexy es, por definición, algo o
alguien que es atractivo o es interesante.
El cielo está lleno de historias
maravillosas y de objetos
lo suficientemente bellos como para que
le dediquemos algunas noches
de nuestras vidas.
Yo me refiero a mí como agrónomo
de profesión y astrónomo de afición.
Yo quise estudiar biología, pero no se
pudo y terminé inscribiéndome como
ingeniero bioquímico, pero terminé
como ingeniero agrónomo.
Y fueron esas noches en el campo las que
terminaron por convencerme de dedicarme
a esta gran afición que es
la de observar el cielo.
Con la idea de apelar un poco más a tus
sentidos y hacerte sentir lo que yo veo,
quiero que me acompañen
en un ejercicio de imaginación.
Para esto me voy a dirigir
a cada uno de ustedes.
Entonces yo te pido que ahí donde
estás te pongas cómodo.
Relajes brazos y piernas, cierres los ojos
y hagas tres respiraciones conmigo.
Comenzamos.
Cierra los ojos e inhala.
Exhala.
Una vez más, inhala.
Relájate.
Pero eso sí, ponte creativo.
Imagina que estás en el campo, en una
tarde soleada y con las nubes formando
caprichosas imágenes y los rayos del sol
proyectando dramáticos contrastes,
a lo lejos ves que llueve.
Incluso si lo llegas a escuchar,
volteas y descubres en el horizonte
que se comienza a formar un iris.
Observas con detenimiento y te das cuenta
cómo los colores de ese arco iris se
ordenan de abajo hacia arriba, comenzando
con el violeta seguido del azul,
luego el verde, después el amarillo,
el naranja y terminando en el rojo.
Sigues observando el arcoíris y descubres
un segundo arcoíris por encima
del primero, pero este tendrá
los colores invertidos.
Eres paciente y esperas
la llegada del atardecer.
Los atardeceres son dignos de observarse
y ver cómo el sol poco a poco se oculta
en el horizonte y
ver cómo pinta el cielo
en una transición
de colores indescriptible.
¿Sigues esperando?
¿Sientes que la temperatura baja?
Viene la noche y los sonidos de la
noche los comenzamos a escuchar.
Volteas hacia arriba y descubres ante tu
sorprendida mirada un cielo lleno
de estrellas y estás formando figuras
que nunca antes habías visto.
Si eres de los que conocen las
constelaciones, seguramente encima de ti
verás al Pegaso.
Verás Andrómeda, Hércules hacia el sur.
Podríamos ver algunas constelaciones del
zodíaco como Virgo, Escorpión, Sagitario
o Capricornio y hacia el norte,
seguramente podremos ver la Gran Osa
Mayor y su compañera la Osa Menor.
Conforme tus ojos se van acostumbrando a
la oscuridad, descubres una tenue banda
de luz que sale del horizonte
y te cruza por encima.
Algo así como un arroyo celeste.
Pues bien, te presento a la Vía Láctea,
la galaxia en la que vives.
De pronto sucede algo inesperado.
Un rayo de luz por encima de ti.
Una estrella fugaz.
La viste y luego ves una segunda,
una tercera y una más.
¿Qué está pasando?
Te has de preguntar.
No te preocupes.
Simple y sencillamente estás en una fecha
de una linda lluvia de estrellas.
Por unos segundos y para terminar, te
dejaré que veas todas
las estrellas fugaces que desees.
Recuerda que es tu ejercicio
de imaginación.
Cinco.
Cuatro. Regresa conmigo en 3, 2, 1.
Abre tus ojos.
Sacude tus brazos.
Regresa conmigo porque quiero platicarte
una experiencia personal.
Hace muchos años, en 1987,
salí a cazar mi primer noche.
Mi primer noche con lluvia de estrellas.
En esta ocasión recuerdo que salí con mi
hermano mayor, unos tres o cuatro amigos
a un rancho no lejos de la ciudad.
Llegamos a este lugar.
Nos pusimos cómodos.
Comenzó la noche.
Comencé a dibujar algunas constelaciones
en el cielo.
Cuando de pronto nuestra primera
estrella fugaz de la noche.
En ese momento, la dinámica cambió.
Pusimos unas cobijas en el piso.
Nos acostamos para exponernos al cielo
y a disfrutar del espectáculo.
Fue inolvidable.
Por momentos veíamos estrellas
fugaces muy emocionados.
Nosotros por lapsos no veíamos nada.
Y todos estos eventos terminan
con la luz del amanecer.
Cuando llegó este momento había que hacer
el conteo porque, dicho sea de paso,
siempre contamos las estrellas
fugaces que vemos.
Nos dimos cuenta de que habíamos visto 183
estrellas fugaces en una sola noche.
Todos coincidimos en que nunca volveríamos
a ver tal cantidad
de estrellas fugaces juntas.
Y así sucedió.
Años después ya estaba yo casado.
Salí con mi señora y unos amigos un poco
más lejos de la ciudad, a ver una lluvia
de estrellas en noviembre.
A esta que le llaman la Leónidas.
Esta ocasión recuerdo yo particularmente
esta lluvia de estrellas.
Venía cargada de bólidos.
Los bólidos son aquellas estrellas fugaces
tan intensas que nuestros cuerpos
llegan a ser sombra en el suelo.
Llegó el amanecer.
Se terminó el espectáculo
y el momento de la verdad.
El conteo.
100, 150, 180, 200, 300, 500, 700, 1000
Esa noche logramos ver más de 1200
estrellas fugaces.
Nuevamente me dije yo para mis adentros
este número ahora sí será imbatible.
Años después.
2001 noviembre, Leónidas.
También los medios de comunicación
especializados decían que no tendríamos
una lluvia de estrellas, que tendríamos
una tormenta de estrellas.
Obvio es que nadie se lo quería perder.
Tomamos nuestros vehículos
en la tarde y salimos de la ciudad.
Ahora sí, con dirección poniente
y muy lejos de la ciudad.
Después de varias horas llegamos a un
lugar que nos habían recomendado
y curiosamente nos encontramos demasiada
gente en ese lugar.
Era un lugar en el desierto, pero no había
momento de ver quién andaba ahí,
de saludar.
Teníamos que llegar, organizarnos
para el conteo y disfrutar de la noche.
La noche fue una locura.
Estrellas fugaces simultáneas, pasando por
encima de nosotros, cruzando por mi
izquierda, cruzando por mi derecha de
varios colores, desdeñamos rojas, verdes,
amarillas, blancas.
Algunas de estas generaban sus trazos
en el cielo y este trazo quedaba
iridiscente por varios minutos.
Escuchábamos gritos de emoción.
No faltó quien llorara incluso.
Y llegó el amanecer.
El espectáculo terminó y
el momento del conteo.
Obviamente pasamos 180, pasamos las 1200,
llevábamos 2000, 3000, 4000.
Vimos esa noche más de 6000
estrellas fugaces.
¿Ustedes creen que esta experiencia se nos
va a olvidar a las más de 500 personas
que finalmente nos dimos cuenta
de que estábamos ahí?
Estas experiencias se quedan para siempre.
Las estrellas fugaces tienen su origen
en polvo cósmico, que está flotando en el
espacio y se impacta
con la atmósfera de la Tierra.
Estos granitos de polvo cósmico pueden ser
tan pequeños como un granito de talco,
así de pequeños o tan grandes
como un grano de arroz.
Mientras estas partículas de polvo cósmico
están en el aire, se les conoce
con el nombre de meteoroides.
Cuando el meteoroides se quema con la
fricción con la atmósfera de la Tierra
y marca ese trazo de luz en el cielo,
este trazo es el que
se le conoce como un meteoro.
Y si el meteoroide no se quema por
completo para generar el meteoro y logra
caer al suelo, a este es al
que se le llama meteorito.
Se calcula que todos los días
caen a la tierra
más de cien toneladas de polvo cósmico.
Comparativamente, esto equivale a 25
elefantes de polvo cósmico cayendo
todos los días sobre la tierra.
Si lo llevamos al año serían más
de 9000 elefantes de polvo.
Por eso digo yo que cualquier noche, sí,
cualquier noche que sea obscura, que no
haya luna de preferencia, que te permitas
estar un rato bajo el cielo,
después de la medianoche, verás estrellas
fugaces cualquier noche.
La historia del hombre y el cielo
ha estado encadenada desde siempre.
El cielo ha sido el reloj
de nuestras actividades.
Como ejemplo, podemos comentar
que la semana,
la semana es el tiempo que tarda
en cambiar la luna de una fase a otra.
Por ejemplo, de luna nueva
a cuarto creciente,
o de creciente a llena,
más o menos 7 días.
El mes es el período que tarda un ciclo
lunar, o sea del tiempo que sucede entre
una luna llena y la siguiente luna llena,
es aproximadamente un mes.
Los días de la semana tienen sus nombres
en honor de los antiguos astros
que conocía la humanidad.
De tal suerte que si ponemos atención nos
daremos cuenta de que el lunes es el día
de la Luna.
El martes obvio de Marte.
El miércoles día de Mercurio.
El jueves día de Júpiter.
El viernes, día de Venus, el
sábado o cambiándolo
al inglés Saturday día de Saturno.
Y el domingo, o Sunday, Día del Sol.
El año que para todos nosotros comienza
siempre el primero de enero
antes no iniciaba el primero de enero,
iniciaba con un evento astronómico,
el equinoccio de primavera.
Marzo.
Tan fácil es descubrir esto como ver los
nombres de algunos de los meses.
Pongan atención y verán cómo septiembre
era el séptimo mes del año.
Octubre, el octavo, noviembre, el
noveno y diciembre el décimo.
¿Quieren conocer más acerca de esto?
Los dejo para que lo investiguen
por su cuenta.
Esta imagen que estamos viendo ahora
es de una región en la constelación
de Géminis.
A la derecha vemos una estructura
globular que es el remanente
de una explosión de una estrella
hace miles de años.
A esta se le conoce como la nebulosa de la
Medusa, de hecho, porque tiene forma
de medusa.
Al fondo y a la izquierda vemos una gran
nube roja y ciertos espacios con polvo
obscuro donde se están formando estrellas
y seguramente nuevos sistemas solares.
Ahora creo prudente presentarles
al autor de esta fotografía.
Él es Pavel Borowiec, un amigo de aquí
de la ciudad que se ha encantado por la
astronomía desde el punto
de vista de la fotografía.
A él le gusta la astrofotografía.
Él no tomó esta fotografía ayudado de un
satélite o de un gran telescopio, lo hizo
desde el mismo techo de su casa, aquí
a las orillas de esta gran ciudad.
Con esto quiero dejar sentado que pueden
ser ustedes los que pueden eventualmente
voltear a ver y encontrar
objetos como este.
Incluso desde una ciudad como esta.
Que no hay que ser científicos locos
para hacer trabajos como este.
Aunque sí se requiere mucho
trabajo y dedicación.
Y que podrían ser ustedes los autores
de estas maravillosas imágenes.
El cielo y la astronomía tienen algo
para cada uno de nosotros.
Si eres de quien gusta de las artes, como
la fotografía, el dibujo, la pintura,
las artes manuales,
seguro podrías dedicar algunos días
en fotografiar la luna, porque cada noche
nos muestra una cara diferente.
O dibujar las constelaciones y sus
conceptualizaciones mitológicas.
Podrías inspirarte en los mismos
colores de las nebulosas.
¿Y por qué no tomar como muestra
el mismo sol y la luna para
hacer tus creaciones manuales?
Ahora, si eres de los que les gustan
las ciencias exactas como la física,
la química, la biología, podrías pensar
incluso en hacer un posgrado
de astrofísica, astrobiología.
¿O por qué no, medicina espacial?
Si eres de quien les gusta la literatura
y la historia, podrías incluso descubrir
esas cartas que están en el Internet que
Sor María Celeste le escribiera
a su padre, Galileo Galilei,
hace más de 400 años.
Ahora, si eres de pensamientos
más místicos o espirituales,
te podrías exponer
a un atardecer para hacer tus oraciones,
hacer una provechosa introspección
o simplemente para meditar.
Si en el corto tiempo que me has
estado escuchando
crees que allá arriba no pasa nada,
déjame decirte que en este tiempo hemos
viajado todos juntos 27 000 kilómetros
alrededor del sol.
Hemos viajado doscientos mil kilómetros
dentro de nuestro sistema solar,
alrededor del centro de nuestra galaxia
y hemos viajado más de medio millón de
kilómetros junto con nuestra Vía Láctea,
en dirección del cúmulo galáctico
en la constelación de Virgo.
Con lo que has escuchado ahora,
coincidirás conmigo en que la astronomía
sí es interesante.
Ya tienes todo lo que necesitas para
comenzar a disfrutar del cielo.
Tus propios ojos.
Solamente necesitas salir
y exponerte a él.
Darte el tiempo de voltear a verlo
y darte el permiso de disfrutarlo.
El cielo está ahí, con miles de historias
maravillosas y de objetos
lo suficientemente bellos
para ser descubiertos por ti.
Atrévete.